je posais la question moi c'est la
première semaine quoi c'est la deuxième
je t'ai dit que non je vais tout en bio
quoi ça fait 25 ans et mes potes c'est
moi qui peut se présenter mais c'est
énorme ça fait mes amis aussi
antoine coan avant qu'on se retrouve à
la patinoire tu l'avais jamais vu
antoine très très mal quelle contrainte
j'étais sorti avec rib bien avant tout
cas comment ça tu es sorti avec antoine
non prescription coûte 8 ans je
l'attendais moment magique
les prescriptions j'ai baisé tapha ya
prescription je te crever un oeil mais
la prescription
j violette hammer la prescription
aujourd'hui olivier rien mec c'est pas
la question je m'en suis jamais mais pas
avant paris qu'un pote pas dans le passé
quoi je veux dire c'est une question de
respect